[Musique]
je lui ai demandé de retenir deux
chiffres 85 et 24 85%
ce sont les gens qui ne tiennent pas
leurs promesses de nouvel an c'est en
2019 je pense que 2020 la tendance est
la même
le 2e chiffre ces 24 et 24 c 24 heures
parce que quoi de plus logique dans le
quotidien que 24 heures
et le facteur temps et je pense que le
quotidien est bien là pour l'illustrer
c'est clairement la chose sur lequel
l'homme n'a pas de prise je peux aller
devant derrière sur le côté en haut en
bas mais le facteur temps une fois que
j'ai bouffé 7 secondes
elle n'est plus là moi est en fait le
temps c'est une logique de clair-obscur
clair parce que ça vous aide en tout cas
dans le temps à oublier certaines choses
et obscur parce qu'en gros c'est aussi
le temps qui vous rapproche de la mort
la logique de tout ça c'est de faire en
sorte que on vit quasiment dans un monde
type star wars ou en gros
clairement on a une logique
effectivement à la dark vador ou à la
maître jedi dark vador parce que c'est
typiquement quand on est face à as
quelque chose qui vous ennuie et on a
l'impression que ces 24 heures durant
une année
et puis quand on est face à quelque
chose qui est amusant on a l'impression
que ces 24 heures passent rapidement et
en fait il faut reprendre le contrôle du
temps est clairement devenir pas le
maître des horloges
mais le maître jedi en tout cas de son
temps je suis emmanuel bavière et je me
considère comme un slasher pourquoi un
slasher parce que vous savez en
informatique quand on met les slash
c'est effectivement pour séparer
certaines activités j'ai plusieurs
activités
j'ai une activité de conseil en digital
d'une activité conseiller municipal je
suis président d'une association qui
fait du social je suis moniteur de
plongée parfois artistes quand j'ai un
peu le temps et je ne sens pas comme
étant un martien je pense qu'aujourd'hui
il ya de plus en plus de personnes qui
sont des slashers et qui font en sorte
justement d'avoir plusieurs activités
je vais vous donner un troisième chiffre
23 % des gens ont déjà plusieurs
activités et ça s'annonce comme étant
grandissante alors être slasher ça veut
dire effectivement être capable de gérer
dans une journée de 24 heures
l'ensemble de ces
activité est d'être capable de bien
remplir sa journée est d'être capable en
tout cas de le sentir une réelle
résilience dans cette cette journée
ensuite une fois qu'on a dit ça est bien
la logique effectivement lié aux
slashing c'est de faire en sorte
qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une vie où on
n'ya plus de séparation entre la vie
personnelle et la vie professionnelle
on le voit bien avec le télétravail on
voit bien avec la capacité qu'on a de
regarder c'est son téléphone mobile
quand on est au travail et puis aussi
parce que par l'apport au télétravail on
peut travailler travailler à la maison
travaillant au bureau naturellement et
puis on n'est plus dans une logique et
je pense que vous êtes bien là pour
l'illustrer
on n'est plus dans une logique de mono
entreprise de d'avoir une seule en tout
cas une trentaine une seule entreprise à
vie ce qui veut dire que cette
séparation est vraiment logique
la seule chose c'est que pour tenir tout
ça dans une journée il faut de la
simplicité et la simplicité et ben ça
s'improvise pas et ça passe
effectivement simplement par des choses
que vous avez appris c'est
majoritairement le fait d'avoir des to
do list est donc tout le monde fait les
to do list avec le sentiment que c'est
tout doux liste elles vont gérer votre
journée est en fait qu'est ce qu'on
apprend c'est qu'en fait quand on gère
les to do list en début de journée en
fait on arrive à la fin de la journée et
on a le sentiment d'être passé à côté
d'avoir remis les choses
le lendemain et c est en fait ce que je
préconise c'est de me dire m'a autant
gérer de façon inverse gérer directement
ce qu'on va appeler une bonne liste dire
la fin de la journée de me dire qu'est
ce que j'ai fait c'est aussi simple que
ça et qu'est ce que j'aurais pu mieux
faire donc c'est tout doux et cette
donne liste vous l'avez en tête garder
la rente est puisque en fait on se rend
compte que dans la logique systémique
d'une vie de slasher comme vous tous
c'est qu'en fait on va avoir besoin de
relier l'ensemble des activités et
d'avoir en tout cas un impact personnel
sur l'ensemble de ses activités
donc moi je m'amuse à relier
effectivement mon rôle de maître de
moniteur de plongée a typiquement les
logique environnementale en demandant à
mes élèves d'aller ramasser justement au
fond de l'eau tout ce qui n'a pas
l'hiver le plastique les filets qui
traîne et c'est quand je suis président
d'une association qui fait de la
médiation
je suis en sorte que ces gens là soient
formés dans le digital parce qu'en tout
cas c'est bien de l'humain c'est bien le
mettre de l'humain partout mais c'est
bien aussi d'en mettre des personnes qui
ont cette capacité à être augmenté quand
je fais de la politique je m'arrange
effectivement à ce qu'ils aient une
combine
on si possible en tout cas assez
agréable entre l'ap la logique sociale
et environnementale
et puis quand j'ai un peu de temps pour
faire de l'art je le fais sur du
matériel de récupération c'est pas plus
compliqué que ça c'est de me dire qu'il
ya bien les biens une logique systémique
qui lie l'ensemble de ses activités et
qui me permet en tout cas d'anticiper le
futur et de me dire tout ce que j'ai pu
faire dans ces activités s'est pas
seulement pour remplir ma journée mais
c'est bel et bien en tout cas pour
arriver à une logique systémique et
d'avoir le sentiment que mon impact
quotidien pendant ces 24 heures il est
réel la condition systémique ensuite
c'est d'être capable de se projeter dans
le futur
donc aujourd'hui on fait plein
d'éléments qui nous permettent en tout
cas de se projeter dans le futur ça soit
la science fiction le dosier le design
fiction il ya plein d'éléments qui vous
permettent de vous projeter dans le
futur et ensuite de définir par rapport
à la réalité du jour comment vous allez
arriver à ce futur et c'est le chemin
qui est le plus important et je vous
propose de ramener ce chemin au
quotidien de 24 heures en fait ce
quotidien de 24 heures il est
omniprésent
c'est l'élément sur lequel on fait
sûrement la logique de dire dans cette
journée est passée très vite je
remettrai au lendemain tout ce que
j'aurais pu faire aujourd'hui est en
fait la logique des 24 heures de ce
quotidien justement c'est de considérer
que en gros c'est une partie qui est pas
un film mais en fait c'est juste la
composante de l'ensemble de votre vie
est donc considéré effectivement que ce
quotidien est pas valorisant ou epa
valorisables en l'état en fait il faut
absolument s'y tenir
parce que justement c'est lui qui va qui
va complètement composer une vie une vie
une vie complète
alors vous allez me dire quel est le sew
en tout cas de tout ça une fois qu'on a
dit ça c'est de considérer que et ben en
fait on est aussi dans la vie de tous
les jours on est aussi un quotidien de
l'ensemble d'une communauté ou d'une
ville ou d'une famille ou d'une école
d'une entreprise et qu'en fait c'est bel
et bien la somme de ces quotidiens qui
va rendre la totalité de l'entreprise ou
la totalité d'une ville complètement
systémique et donc de faire en sorte
d'avoir une composante qui soit qu'ils
soient complètement lié est en fait le
l'élément qui reprend pas mal ça c'est
c'est la légende de pierre rabhi
connaissez avec le colibri c'est le
pauvre colibri qui essayent
effectivement d'éteindre la forêt avec
son petit bec et voyez bien qu'en fait
la part de chacun et aussi importante
puisqu'en fait pour éteindre la forêt il
suffit juste que les gens qui critiquent
le colibri parce qu'ils amènent juste un
gramme de enfin décilitre un centilitres
de dos fassent aussi leur boulot et donc
en fait la compréhension de tout ça
c'est dire ben moi si je fais mon boulot
je peux considérer que si les autres
font leur boulot à leur mesure
on arrivera justement à changer le futur
avoir un impact réel sur le futur donc
je vous propose effectivement garder ça
en tête et de faire ensemble de
considérer qu'aujourd'hui le quotidien
est important le quotidien se mesure en
24 heures le quotidien doit être
systématiquement intégrée et peser
justement sur le fait de dire qu'est ce
que j'ai fait de mon quotidien et
comment justement j'arrive à l'améliorer
au quotidien par rapport à un autre
quotidien et donc de jour en jour et
garder en tête justement cette logique
de dire ben comment je peux contribuer à
tout ça et je vais finir par une
citation de tolstoï qui disait tout le
monde veut changer la planète mais
personne ne veut se changer soi même
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]